but panksepp observed I think this is a
brilliant piece of science is that first
of all juvenile male routes in
particular like to rough-and-tumble play
they like to wrestle and they actually
pin each other just like little kids do
or like adult wrestlers do they pin
their shoulders down and that basically
means you win and so okay so that's
pretty cool but what's even cooler I
think well there's three things one is
the rats will work for an opportunity to
get into an arena where they know that
play might occur and so that's one of
the scientific ways of testing and
animals motivation right so imagine you
have a starving rat and it knows that
it's got food down the end of a corridor
you can put a little spring on its tail
and measure how hard it pulls and that
gives you an indication of its
motivational force now imagine the
starving rat that's trying to get to
some food and you have a little spring
on his tail and you waft in some cat
odour so now that rat is starving and
wants to get out of there he's going to
try to pull even farther towards the
food so getting away plus getting
forward our separate motivational
systems and if you can add them together
it's real potent and part of the reason
why in the future authoring exercise
that you guys are going to do as the
class progresses you're asked to outline
the place you'd like to end up which is
your desired future and also the place
that you could end up if you let
everything fall apart is so that your
anxiety chases you and your approach
systems pull you forward
you're maximally motivated dead and it's
important because otherwise you can be
afraid of pursuing the things that you
want to pursue right and that's very
common and so then the fear inhibits you
as the promise pulls you forward but it
makes you weak because you're afraid you
want to get your fear behind you pushing
you and so what you want to be is afraid
more afraid of not pursuing your goals
then you are of pursuing them it's very
very helpful and lots of times in life
and this is something really worth
knowing you know and what this is one of
the advantages to being an autonomous
adult is you don't get to pick the best
thing you get to pick your poison you
have two bad choices and you get to pick
which one you're willing to suffer
through and every choice has a bit of
that element in it and so if you know
that it's really freeing because
otherwise you torture yourself
by thinking well maybe there's a good
solution to this you know compared to
the bad solution it's like nah nah
sometimes there's just risky solution
one and risky solution two and sometimes
both of them are really bad but you at
least get to pick which one you're
willing to suffer through and that's
that actually makes quite a bit of
difference because you're also facing it
voluntarily then instead of it chasing
you and that is an entire different
entirely different cycle physiological
response challenge versus threat it's
not the same even if the magnitude of
the problem is the same and so putting
yourself in a challenging let's call it
mind frame you can't just do that by
magic putting yourself in a challenging
mind frame is much better much easier on
you cycle physiologically because you
don't produce you don't go into the
generalized stress response to the same
degree and you're activating your
exploratory and seeking systems which
are dopaminergic Lee mediated and that
involve positive emotion so if you can
face something voluntarily rather than
having it chase you it's way better for
you psycho physiologically so that's
partly why well it's worthwhile to go
find the dragon in its lair instead of
waiting for it to come and eat you so
and especially when you also add the
idea that if you go find the dragon in
its lair you might find it when it's a
baby instead of a full-fledged bloody
monster that is definitely gonna take
you down and so that's part of the
reason why well there's a whole bunch of
things that that that emerge out of that
observation like don't avoid small
problems that you know are there face
them because they'll grow into big
problems all by themselves and you can
think about imagine the tax department
sends you a notification you owe them
like $300 well it's you know that's
annoying maybe you don't even want to
open the letter or maybe if you do you
just put it on the shelf but that damn
thing doesn't just sit there like a
piece of paper on the shelf right you
ignore that for five or six years it's
gonna become attached to all sorts of
horrible things and if you ignore it
long enough you get the idea it's gonna
turn into something that is completely
unlike the little piece of paper that
it's written on and and many many
problems in life are like that you'll
see they'll you'll see that they pop
they're ugh
little head up and you know and you
might want to turn away might not want
not want to think about it which is the
easiest way of turning away right you
just don't attend to it it's not like
you repress it or anything like that you
just fail to attend to it and that's of
really as a long-term strategy it's
dismal it's also something I think
that's more characteristic of people who
are high in neuroticism and high in
agreeableness because agreeable people
don't like conflict and people who are
high in neuroticism we were high
negative emotion are hit harder per unit
of uncertainty or threat and so you know
and that's partly why in psychotherapy a
lot of times the people you see need
assertiveness training so that would be
the opposite of agreeableness or they
need to help get their anxiety and
emotional pain under control
it's those are not the only reasons
there's antisocial behavior but you
can't fix that in therapy in all
likelihood there's alcoholism there's
lots and lots of other reasons but those
are two major reasons